5 25 in your monday morning we're diving
right back into the big squeezy on the
95 5 15 at a week off for special
reports on the most dangerous
intersections in las vegas so back to
covering what's driving you crazy in the
daily grind of your commute or
whatever's bothering you on your
neighborhood street so when it comes to
those one or two night ramp closures or
lane restrictions on the big squeeze i
usually just refer you to the always up
to date closures section of ndot's
i515project.com website but that's where
this longer term closure kind of caught
my eye starting sometime next month
you're not going to be able to get off
the south 95 515 at eastern for five
weeks a specific start time to be
determined it is going to affect a lot
of drivers so i'll for sure let you know
about that as soon as i know and a shout
out to the folks at the weekend
fundraiser for the san antonio padua
school who let me know they're fans of
buckle up drive carefully and please put
down that phone something's driving you
crazy email me traffic 8 8 news now dot
com